Why can't we buy these tanks the Army says
they don't need?
Why can't we buy these solar-powered abortion
machines?
Uh, we got 20 trillion reasons.
Got 20 trillion reasons?
We got 20 trillion reasons.
About 20 trillion reasons.
Why can't we build a border wall that touches
the skies?
Stay on our momma's healthcare until we're
45?
We got 20 trillion reasons.
Got 20 trillion reasons?
About 20 trillion reasons.
We took centuries
to reach 10, now I fear we're gleaning
Debt is like this guy
it should be nowhere near the teens and
we've got about 20 trillion reasons to
stop today
But maybe if we just spend one more we'll
stay.
Twenty trillion dollars stacked together just
might reach to the sun.
So?
It could even last Johnny Depp for over a
month.
Dear God...
We got 20 trillion reasons.
Got 20 trillion reasons?
We got 20 trillions reasons.
Over have 20 trillion reasons.
We could pay off the tab by buying unneeded
jets?
Or just identify as being not that in debt?
No, we'd still have 20 trillion reasons
Still the 20 trillion reasons?
Still have 20 trillion reasons.
Over 20 trillion reasons.
I've paid social security since I was first
hired
Will that program still exist on the day I
retire?
I forgot my car
is parked in the two hour parking
Lord, show me the way
I think I hear my third wife carping
I got a pot of sauce I left on the oven range,
but baby let me just spend one more...
I ain't gonna pay.
It ain't me who's gonna pay.